sharp
how do you come across him is this
somebody that you saw and you thought he
was talented did you know right away
what is the growth for him
sharp uh so there's a podcast called
software at underbelly well not podcast
he just does these interviews mark
martin stills what's his name stills or
something mark [ __ ] i forget ben uh
latia
yeah he's got some great interviews too
yeah um yes and he has a studio in
downtown l.a and he just does interviews
with a lot of you know street people uh
prostitutes uh escorts uh drug addicts
pimps drug addicts yeah and and sharp is
someone who went on there uh he
allegedly was a pimp earlier in his life
and uh he's a huge deal in that scene
too because he's he's won like player of
the year pimp of the year or whatever at
these big conventions that they do and
stuff which i'll be honest i'm kind of
in the dark about how you
get to be viewed as number one in that
yeah
magic don juan it was like kind of like
the king of that [ __ ] for a long time
and it's still like an icon in that game
but uh yeah i saw him on uh on on
software underbelly somebody reached out
and said would you be down to have sharp
on i had him on it does like two million
views right away and i just was like oh
you know i should
we already had like a couple different
hosts like a.d and tyrell on the channel
and i just figured you know why don't i
just try to get this guy to do episodes
on my channel because i really i the
thing that came to mind immediately was
like i need to see this guy talking to
women like i just really want to know
what a place what the energy is going to
be like you know
and uh that's what we did just from the
start and to be honest he was a little
aggressive early on like he was really
really uh just kind of talking over him
and just like barking on him and i feel
like he's gotten a shitload better on
camera where he's having like you know
real mature conversations with a lot of
them but then at the same time i mean he
has a lot of triggers like if you call
him a [ __ ]
oh my god the girls keep calling them
[ __ ] but but it isn't like a girl way
of being like [ __ ]
oh my god he just gets so [ __ ] pissed
but yeah i mean he's been
he's definitely one of the biggest uh
things that we got going on the channel
it's just been insane seeing the way
that people gravitate too much so much
and i've been in vegas with him and
seeing the way it is on the street where
there are a shitload of sharp wannabes
who are really on various degrees of the
spectrum some of them almost have like
his look some of them just kind of are
trying to talk like him and trying to
talk to girls all reckless on the street
and [ __ ] but i mean we couldn't go
anywhere without him getting stopped
left and right to take photos it was
[ __ ] insane yeah and then what's
what's happening in his life like is has
he made this transition to legit
business and and how is that changing
him is
i mean he's a very mysterious guy we
really like i facetime him sometimes and
he'll be the middle of the night and
he's just like with his daughter he's
like [ __ ] apparently got a kind of
normal life that i don't even really
like ask that much about but he uh he
definitely keeps an oar of mystery but
yeah he's definitely on the up and up as
far as uh the illegal side of things i
believe at this point yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's just really interesting
character you guys should check them out
you guys have these great guys i love
you guys hey i would love to get them
out here to talk to you yeah it's
amazing oh my god no i'd love to have a
conversation i'm just curious about like
that life but also dunno a d t rally all
those guys are just [ __ ]
just yeah you guys got something really
cool are you on to flocco yet no oh my
god send me something
i'm sure you two will recommend him soon
enough
but a portly guy from uh from north
dakota well he's actually from liberia
which is just the gnarliest part of
africa apparently because that's where
general butt naked is from
do you remember him from the vice
documentary yeah yeah oh my god wasn't a
comedian that guy is the [ __ ] pastor
at the church that this kid flaco grew
up going to for real i guess yeah but
then he moved to north dakota when he
was young and then we've got him on the
channel and i've never met anyone who is
less afraid of having a controversial
opinion in my [ __ ] life he's off the
chain with it oh that's he's he's just
like what are some of his hot tastes
well like people uh getting uh thrown in
prison like rappers and stuff and he'll
just be like hey lock him up like he's
like he he's fully like wishing prison
upon them based on the accusation so
we're trying to like coach him into it
like these are just accusations he
hasn't even gone to trial yeah you can't
be wishing prison upon people and uh
that's crazy yeah he knew general but
naked he's apparently i think if no
jumper doesn't work out he might end up
in a world naked army you gotta get him
you gotta get general but naked
oh my
have you not seen this guy he's an
unbelievable he's like a standard
comedian they did a dock on him
to interview him like in africa like
doing comedy right like this is the guy
we're talking about yeah and he would
talk about how he would he would eat a
baby uh before battle yeah he would just
consume a baby yeah which was kind of
troubling insane human being liberia is
what
yeah it's no it's average but didn't
like america play a role in the creation
of liberia i don't know but it was also
like one board right
yeah i'm not sure conflict diamond
yeah yeah i have no idea you have all
these guys under the no jumper banner
you ever get afraid if they say
something that it can affect the company
um well we don't really uh make that big
a percentage of our money from like
advertisers or anything so even if
somebody were to try to kind of get us
canceled i don't know how much it would
really uh do but
yeah there's definitely been times like
a.d when he first came in like uh we
were doing the news and we were talking
about 69 snitching and he he just looks
right at the camera and he's like
well
if it was me if i couldn't get to him i
would kill his mom
and i'm just like okay that's gonna fall
into the category of things we can't say
there are things that you know when
you're dealing with people they they he
didn't know and now he knows and now
he's much more professional about saying
stuff like that so there's a lot of uh
blocks learning blocks over time yeah i
caught that that uh a.d china mack
uh beef to friendship i thought that was
really cool yeah
right yeah it was cool they had a little
squabble or something like that and then
because we had china mac on the pod oh
wow back on brilliant idiots oh right
yeah and uh
and this was like years this is years
ago but i thought it was cool they like
worked it out as dudes it didn't get
violent besides you know the hands and
then they're like doing content together
doing the the cooking show it seems odd
to me that they were beefing over food
vlogs in the first place but this is
your fault
i had a lot of people putting it on me
i mean i guess china mac is just kind of
a protective of his of his food vlogging
content but yeah i mean it was overall
pretty good because yeah a.d has been
doing these food vlogs that are just
going crazy they just did one at
blueface's uh soul food restaurant and
[ __ ] right yeah shit's going crazy yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you